[Musique]
pouvez-vous me présenter comme Joker l'une des
premières choses que j'ai faites a été que j'ai commencé à
étudier les médicaments et vraiment les effets
secondaires et j'étais curieux de connaître les
villes sur sept médicaments différents
et et euh et donc je sorte de vous savez
lire en ligne et lire à
ce sujet et tout le monde là-bas tous ces babillards
électroniques remplis de gens parlant de
ces changements extrêmes de poids, soit
ils ont pris du poids, soit ils ont perdu du poids
et il semblait que c'était ce
thème commun pour tant de gens et donc c'est
vraiment  ce qui a motivé l'idée qu'il
soit mince, c'était le début et
j'ai juste travaillé avec ce
nutritionniste auparavant et juste un
régime très strict et j'étais bien sûr que je
veux dire comme oui évidemment
c'est vraiment vraiment comme si c'était comme 500
calories par  jour si gentil de perdre du
poids, vous savez, cela peut être difficile, mais
étonnamment, aidez-moi à trouver une grande partie du
mouvement du personnage, des choses
que je n'avais pas anticipées, mais je pense que
vous en prenez conscience  de votre corps d'
une manière différente
[Musique]
la scène du film où
Arthur danse dans la salle de bain qui
n'était pas dans le scénario c'était juste
quelque chose qui marchait et j'ai commencé à en
parler et j'ai commencé à lui jouer de la
musique et il  Je viens juste de commencer à faire cette
danse et nous avons décidé que cela devrait être
dans le film, cela m'a fait peur,
c'était difficile à bien des égards, euh en tant
qu'acteur, mais cela a également mis au défi mes
propres sentiments à propos du personnage de mon
défi mon empathie et vous savez c'est
vraiment  c'était c'était difficile c'était un
personnage difficile ce film difficile n'a pas
fourni de réponses ou de solutions faciles
il y a une grande ambiguïté et
j'aime vraiment ça
[Musique]
il était très nerveux à propos de sa capacité à
faire ça rit dans le  film si vous avez vu
le film et qu'il se lit très simplement,
vous savez qu'Arthur commence à rire, cela ressemble
à un rire douloureux et et pour un
acteur, c'est beaucoup plus difficile qu'il ne le
lit, alors il voulait s'assurer que
c'était en ligne  esprit  h ce que je pensais donc
nous avons travaillé sur ce rire pendant un moment j'ai
étudié ces vidéos ce sont des
gens qui ont ces
fous rires incontrôlables et moi et j'ai étudié
ça et puis je ne sais vraiment pas comment l'
expliquer vous savez alors  tu essaies juste
et tu fais beaucoup d'erreurs tu sais
qu'il y a une scène dans le film
qui date du deuxième jour de tournage
et je ne l'avais pas encore trouvée et je
déteste la scène parce que
ça semble forcé et ça semble  faux et
je ne l'avais pas encore vraiment trouvé
mais il y avait des jours où
ça ne venait pas facilement et puis
parfois ce serait plus facile et donc comme
vous l'obteniez en deux prises puis les
trois suivantes  Je prends juste que ça ne marcherait pas
tu sais pour une raison quelconque donc ce
n'était pas une science comme ça Je n'ai pas
compris comment l'allumer à chaque
fois que nous l'avons fait Je le découvrais
[Musique]
le nuage que
tu
[  Musique]
vous